-This is how this works.
We are going to have a number of
mystery objects brought out
in front of us, and our job
is to guess what each one is.
The catch is that we have to
figure it out by touch alone.
-Oh, my gosh.
-I know, I know.
I'm freaking out.
Alright, alright, alright.
Reese, since you're my guest,
you'll go first.
-What?!
-Yeah.
Let's bring in
our first object here.
You'll have 30 seconds
to identify what this is.
You just put your hands in
that -- in the thing there.
And...
-There's a strong smell.
There's a strong smell! Aah!
It's smells really bad.
Hey!
Aah!
-Aah!
-I'm scared!
-No, don't!
-Okay, I got to just do it.
Okay.
-Oh!
♪♪
Okay. It's like pudding
or something
with, like, graham crackers?
-Yeah, something like that.
-Graham-cracker pudding?
-I think I'll give her
credit for that, right?
-Melted chocolate
or melted candy.
-Yes, yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Dinging ]
There's a towel right there.
You'll get it -- Snickers bars.
You got an easy one.
-Oh, that looks nasty.
-So gross. Yeah. All right.
Here we go. All right.
Now it's my turn.
Oh, God.
-Oh, yeah. Okay, okay.
-Ooh!
♪♪
-Can I look at it?
-Mm-hmm.
-Oh. Ew.
♪♪
Yuck!
Ew!
That's disgusting.
-Why would you say, "Ew"?
It's disgusting? Ew!
-Yeah.
Aah! Oh, oh!
Oh, okay.
-Stop.
I'm looking at the people
in the audience,
and they're freaking me out.
Ugh!
-Wait. Is it moving?
-No, it's not moving!
-Oh, my God!
-Stop, stop, stop, stop, stop!
Just stop it right now.
Just stop it!
Oh, my gosh!
Just everyone -- Just stop
hitting the cymbal.
It's just freaking me out. Gosh!
All right.
-Oh!
Yeah, you're getting close.
You're getting closer.
Okay, okay, okay.
Aah! Aah!
Aah! Aah! You have it.
You have it.
-I have no idea
what this thing is.
Is it...
Oh, is it a gourd?
-Yeah.
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-It's your acting.
It's your acting
that got me all upset. Alright.
Reese, it's your turn now.
Here we go.
I don't want to see this.
-Okay.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah!
-Okay. I'm a little nervous.
Aah! Is it breathing?
Is it breathing?
-No!
-Aah!
-Oh!
Oh, my goodness! Oh, my God!
-Shut up! Shut up!
-Ew!
-There's nothing there.
-There's nothing there,
but something's there!
-My arms are too short.
-I hope it doesn't...
-[ Laughing ] My arms are too...
-Put it back in.
-I can't touch it.
Oh, my God.
Is that a mouth guard?
-Yeah, something like that.
It's teeth.
Yeah, it's fake teeth.
Fake teeth. Fake teeth.
That was the funniest thing.
Alright. I'm up again.
Here we go.
-I have, like, T. rex arms.
Oh, my God. This is so funny.
Oh, my God. Oh, my God!
Can you take a pass?
'Cause this is bad.
[ Drumroll ]
Oh, my God.
-Stop!
-They always do -- They save
these weird ones for me,
and I always hate it.
Ooh! Is it moving?
-Mnh-mnh. Oh.
Yeah, it was --
Whoa! It's moving.
[ Both screaming ]
-Is that --
Is there a spider in there?
-Yeah.
[ Dinging ]
-I got it?
-Yeah, you got it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
It's not real. This is so funny,
this game.
-God, it's not real.
If that was a real spider,
I would have quit the show.
I really would. Alright.
It's time for the final round.
This one, we're both going
to get the same item,
and the first person
to guess it wins, okay?
You put one arm in there.
I put one arm in this one.
-Okay.
♪♪
[ Drumroll ]
-Ew!
-What?
-I can see it.
-You can see it?
-It's up there.
-You just saw it?
-Well, something is
looking at me,
but I don't know what it was.
-It has his eyes?
-It's looking at me.
Alright.
-Gosh.
[ Both scream ]
Stop it! Is it moving?
Is it moving?
It's moving. Oh, my gosh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay. Okay, okay.
-Alright.
Aah! It's moving,
it's moving, it's moving!
It's moving, it's moving.
I saw something moving.
Oh, my gosh! I saw it, too.
It's moving.
-Okay, we just have to do this.
-Yep. Alright, go.
-3, 2, 1, go.
[ Both screaming ]
-There's a person in there.
What are you doing?
My thanks to Reese Witherspoon.
Stick around.
We're talking to Reese
after the break.
-That was crazy.
-Dude.
-That was crazy. That was crazy.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry.